[Music]  we needed a miracle and then we got one  this beautiful and special little  creature will be a revolution in the  livestock industry our super pigs will  not only be big and beautiful it will  also leave a minimal footprint on the  environment consume less feed and  produce less excretions and most  importantly they need to taste [ __ ]  good  [Music]  [Music]  nature we are animal lovers our plan is  to expose Miranda rescued Pope Joe and  bring her back to you he cool ten years  in planning on the customer the products  that will feed millions so what happens  that farmer girl he's gonna destroy us  you should know the situation is not  good  he's not before you  [Music]  such a shame you had to tell all those  little white lies  gentlemen together  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]